herzlich willkommen ja wir haben es
immer wieder versucht und jetzt hat es
geklappt hier in berlin
mir gegenüber sitzt einer der
bedeutendsten intellektuellen unserer
zeit der soziologe richard sennett im
zentrum seines denkens steht der mensch
und die frage was der kapitalismus die
heutige arbeitswelt und die zunehmende
verstädterung mit uns menschen machen
herzlich willkommen sein ich denke ja
die schwierigste frage gleich zu beginn
was ist der mensch wunder wer weiß das
schon
auf diese frage habe ich keine einfache
antwort
in meiner arbeiten lasse ich mich damit
wie menschen ihr leben gestalten und
nicht so sehr mit der biologie aber
vielleicht wird das im zoo der
künstlichen intelligenz immer weniger
bedeutsam und man müsste tatsächlich
zurückgehen auf die biologischen
grundlagen aber dass es nicht meine welt
sie ist soziologe sie interessieren sich
dafür was die gesellschaft mit uns
menschen macht und sie haben vor 20
jahren dieses buch her geschrieben der
flexible mensch darin behaupten sie dass
die heutige arbeitswelt und unser
wirtschaftssystem uns menschen innerlich
kaputt macht glauben sie dass heute nach
heute ist es sogar noch schlimmer als
vor 20 jahren
ich beschrieb damals wie immens der
druck auf den einzelnen man die einzelne
frau bei der arbeit gestiegen ist
heute stehen wir an der schwelle einer
entwicklung in der maschinen über
menschen herrschen könnten
in der politik fehlt der diskurs über
die auswirkungen der automatisierung auf
unser arbeitsleben
ich habe kürzlich das buch noch einmal
durchgelesen und ich musste mich dafür
loben aber damals wusste ich noch nicht
einmal die hälfte
wir werden uns in zukunft mit dem
gedanken auseinandersetzen müssen dass
menschen überflüssig werden
das über die reine funktions erfüllung
der mensch und menschliche beziehungen
nichts mehr gelten
und das ist zu verwahren als dass sich
die politik damit beschäftigt weil es
einfacher ist sich mit bekannten
problemstellungen zu befassen
zum beispiel ob emigranten der
ansässigen bevölkerung die arbeitsplätze
wegnähmen
als sich mit der tatsache auseinander zu
setzen dass es vielleicht bald überhaupt
keine arbeit mehr gibt eine rückständige
debatte über migration lässt sich leicht
führen
es ist aber alles andere als einfach die
folgen davon ab zu schätzen dass ein
drittel der bevölkerung nicht mehr
arbeiten muss ein ganz anderes system
lösen arbeit neu definieren und so
weiter ich möchte mit ihnen gegen ende
der sendung noch darüber sprechen jetzt
nochmal zu diesem zu diesem diesem buch
der flexible mensch auf englisch heißt
der titel der korrosion of care also die
zersetzung des charakters das heißt sie
sagen auch durch dieses unsere
lebensweise und das wirtschaftssystem
gegen bestimmte charakterzüge und
tugenden verloren können sie das ein
bisschen erläutern
ich gebe ihnen ein beispiel die meisten
menschen brauchen eine strategie ein
lebensnaher aktiv woraus sich auch die
sinnhaftigkeit ihrer arbeite gibt
menschen die c einfachen manuellen
tätigkeiten empfinden vielleicht die
genugtuung dass es ihren kindern einmal
besser gehen wird in eine
wirtschaftsordnung die keine karriere
mehr kennt sondern nur noch serielle
arbeit also eine aneinanderreihung von
jobs gibt es das narrativ einer laufbahn
nicht mehr bei dem man vorher gelerntem
aufbaut
das meine ich mit der zersetzung des
charakters in der kapitalistischen
beschleunigung der arbeitsorganisation
verlieren die menschen das gefühl für
ihre selbst salz und damit wie ihr
negativ belassen
aber das kann doch auch befreiend sein
früher musste man das ganze leben lang
brote backen oder schule machen
und jetzt kann man zehn jahre das machen
und damals anderes das ist doch befreien
sie sind sein optimist haben sie für ihn
zehn jahren besser zu werden wohl eher
nicht das problem ist dass nur eine
kleine elite wirklich mobil genug ist
leicht von einem job zum anderen zu
wechseln wir die mittelklasse sind
kribbelt herausgefordert da arbeit nicht
mehr langfristig ist durch die
automatisierung immer weniger wird
das ist keine verheißungsvolle vision
ich möchte dazu anregen sich zu
überlegen wie man heute wertschätzung
erfahren kann wenn sie vier jahre lang
für über gefahren sind sollten sie dafür
eine anerkennung erhalten
es gibt in der arbeitswelt nur sehr
wenig wertschätzung für das geleistete
es geht heute nur noch darum einen job
möglichst gut und vor allem billig zu
erledigen
in diesem arbeitskontakte stehen wir
heute
context aware ich meinen darunter leiden
viele unter diesen fehlenden fehlender
wertschätzung auch anerkennen
iris ihre biografie selbst hat ja brüche
darin und dieselben selbst zur
flexibilität gezwungen kann man sagen
eigentlich wollten sie ja musiker werden
sie haben cello studierte
musikwissenschaften mussten dann aber in
jungen jahren operiert werden an ihrer
hand und mussten diesen lebenstraum die
berufung eigentlich auch aufgeben
wie lange hat das gedauert bis ich das
verarbeitet haben ich habe mich bis
heute nicht damit abgefunden hat ohne
diese verletzung oder wenn ich mein
leben noch einmal leben müsste wäre ich
musiker natürlich bin ich froh über die
bücher die ich geschrieben habe
aber um auf ihre persönliche frage zu
antworten das habe ich nie hinter mir
gelassen
[Musik]
aber das war ein unfall ein physisches
trauma worüber er aber spreche in der
arbeitswelt ist durchaus so gewollt dass
arbeit kürzer und weniger wird und es im
gegenzug mehr und mehr unsicherheit geht
es ist das resultat davon arbeite auf
eine bestimmte art zu organisieren und
zu finanzieren
dagegen könnte man etwas tun meine
eigene geschichte ist pathetisch und ja
ich zerfließe vor selbstmitleid aber das
ist dafür kein beispiel nur musste das
ist klar sonst ist es das
wirtschaftssystem das flexibel sein muss
weil sich alles schneller und schneller
bewegt und so weiter ich möchte noch ein
bisschen bei der musik bleiben was sie
machen ja jetzt wieder musik sie spielen
wieder stellung sie denken auch über
musik nach was bedeutet die musik meine
erfahrungen mit der musik sind in meine
soziologischen bücher eingeflossen
beispielsweise bei der frage wie
menschen zusammenarbeiten
weinproben in unserem streichquartett
geht es eigentlich nur darum wenn wir
nicht zusammenarbeiten wird es chaotisch
da kann man der größte virtuose sein
verfassen meines buches zusammenarbeit
ach sie haben es hier das ist jetzt ein
bisschen schlecht werbung stütze ich
mich auf dieser erfahrung der musiker
die zusammenarbeiten müssen
auch der solist muss im zusammenspiel
mit einer kiste auf die anderen hören
mich interessierte vor allem wie
kontextabhängig diese zusammenarbeit ist
würden wir beide das ravel dur für
violine und cello zusammenspielen
kommunizierten wir mittels unserer
augenbrauen und über kleine gesten
wir würden einander nicht fragen was
bedeutet das möchtest du hier machen
mir scheint dass auch in der normalen
arbeitswelt diese informelle nonverbale
zusammenarbeit wichtig wäre es sehr
schwierig per e-mail zusammenzuarbeiten
weil man ohne räumlichen bezug die
gesten der anderen nicht mitbekommt die
künstler auf der bühne müssen wissen wo
sie räumlich sind in bezug auf die
anderen
das war auch in den werkstätten von
grundsätzlicher bedeutung
online ist dieses kontextbezogene lernen
voneinander allerdings schwierig kontext
würden sie sagen dass man durch das
gemeinsame musizieren mehr empathie
entwickeln kann ein besserer sozialer
mensch wert überhaupt nicht ich bin ein
unverbesserlicher juni zurück zum thema
zu kommen wir personalisieren die
zusammenarbeit verstärkt wir hatten ja
alle die erfahrung gemacht wie es ist
mit jemandem zusammenzuarbeiten die man
nicht mag
arbeitskollegen sind nicht immer freunde
deshalb ist es wichtig dass man sich in
der arbeitswelt um die zusammenarbeit
als solche bemüht und sie nicht von den
personen abhängig macht mit denen man
zusammenarbeitet das gilt besonders für
die musik wo man im park esther jede
woche mit anderen kollegen spielt dafür
braucht es rituale wie man einander
zuhört berufsmusiker wissen dass es ist
in der normalen arbeitswelt nicht so
einfach mit fremden zusammenzuarbeiten
das liegt auch diesem buch und dem buch
craftsman zugrunde das booking hamburg
könnte kretschmann
was ist das auf deutsch im handwerk ja
es ist eher eine kunstfertigkeit oder
eine fähigkeit ich weiß es nicht es ist
schwierig zu übersetzen
das buch ist der beginn einer trilogie
zum thema homo faber also darüber dinge
herzustellen
das buch handwerk befasst sich mit der
beziehung zwischen hand rät er in eine
musikalische idee sicherlich aber als
menschliche tiere die wir sind denken
wir beim lernen auch mit unserem körper
anders als ich das der philosoph rené
descartes vorstellte
das zweite buch zusammenarbeit
beschreibt dann wie es ist mit anderen
zusammenzuarbeiten wir haben ja gerade
darüber gesprochen und im dritten geht
es um die gestaltung der umgebung in der
man mit anderen zusammenarbeitet
da geht es dann um die stadt genau das
nicht interessiert jetzt an dieser
stelle wo sie dieses handwerk erwähnt
haben
es kam nach aus kunstfertigkeit
übersetzt und sie sagen damit meinen sie
heißt dass man etwas um seiner selbst
willen möglichst gut machen möchte
und genau diese diese haltung zur
eigenen arbeit dass es eher um den
prozess geht also das den profit den man
damit macht das geht verloren sagt sie
es geht verloren bei bestimmten arbeiten
und an maschinen und im bestreben den
günstigsten anbieter zu finden
ich würde aber nicht sagen dass man
generell das interesse daran verloren
hat eine sache gut machen zu wollen und
sein handwerk zu pflegen
über becker sprachen wir ja gerade wir
haben eine studie in einem modernen
backbetrieb durchgeführt die arbeit ist
zwar stark mechanisiert aber auch da
suchen die leute genug tue bei ihrer
arbeit habt sie bemühen sich nicht zu
viele fehler zu machen und um eine gute
beziehung zu ihrem kollegen die zweifeln
hierarchien an und sie fühlen sich
besser wenn sie glauben ihre
vorgesetzten wären inkompetent das
schafft nähe und gibt den menschen ein
gefühl das machen
das entspricht einen menschlichen
grundbedürfnis und in welchen jobs geht
das heute verloren oder ist das nicht
mehr da diese grundhaltung
die vorstellung dass es keine rolle
spielt ob man seine sache dies macht
findet sich verbreitet im unteren
dienstleistungsbereich zum beispiel wenn
stimm erkennungssoftware bestimmt ob ein
sachbearbeiter übernehmen soll
wer also diener der stimmt
erkennungssoftware ist fühlt sich seine
arbeit entfremdet sie meint
forschungsteam in einer studie
herausgefunden hat umgekehrt aber
empfinden viele die körperliche arbeit
verrichten genugtuung bei ihrer
tätigkeit auch in bestimmten
professionen in der medizin und sogar
unter lehrpersonen gibt es diese
arbeitsethik nach ich glaube aber nicht
dass selbstachtung ohne arbeit möglich
ist da bin ich sehr protestantisch
deshalb müssen unsere wohlfahrtssysteme
die menschen in brot und arbeit setzen
was oft nicht geschieht
so dürfen migranten in einem
europäischen land ohne papiere meistens
nicht arbeiten und das ist für die
meisten migranten in diesem
bürokratischen schwebezustand ein
schrecklicher schlag
sie fühlen sich unwerth und können sich
nicht beweisen sich selbst und anderen
gegenüber
daraus lassen sich also sehr praktische
dinge ableiten
sie sagen die arbeit ist ganz zentral
für das eigene selbstwertgefühl wenn ich
sie richtig verstehe und spannend finde
ich das eben dieses jahren mit der hand
wieder zusammenbringen
sagen irgendwie wie sie das gesagt haben
also wir denken mit den händen und sie
machen das persönliche als sie schreiben
habe ich gelesen immer noch von hand mit
stift und nicht am computer und sie
geben ihnen die ihrer freizeit sind sie
im garten oder in der küche machen musik
sehr sinnliche körperliche tätigkeiten
kommen sie da auf die guten gedanken
oder ist das eher eine kompensation
ihrer intellektuellen tätigkeit
ich würde wohl nicht gut schreiben wir
nicht den ganzen tag am computer sitzen
müsste und ob ich gut schreibe sei
dahingestellt mein tag ist durch den
wechsel von physischen aktivitäten und
dem schreiben rhythmisiert das schreiben
mit dem bleistift ist wie das zeichnen
für den architekten ein architekt denkt
anders wenn er zeichnet als wenn er in
einem cad programm am computer punkte
verbindet die handbewegungen und auch
der auflagedruck nehmen die gedanklichen
prozesse auf denselben experimentellen
zugang finde ich ihm schreiben
aber sie haben vor einigen jahren ein
schicksalsschlag erlitten muss ich alle
diese fähigkeiten verloren haben einen
schlaganfall
was hat das mit ihrem leben gemacht da
sehen sie dass das leben heute anders
verarbeitet
naja es ist anders ich hatte ja
irgendwie glück weil ich trotz meines
schlaganfalls meine kognitiven
fähigkeiten behielt ich konnte also
immer noch denken aber weil sie mich
gefragt haben ja ich musste das gehen es
schreiben mit dem stift wieder erlernen
was sehr schwierig ist und ich musste
auch wieder lernen richtig zu sprechen
aber man schafft das einem hirnschlag
weiß man nie was mit dem gehirn
geschieht
ich hatte glück weil ich ein gutes
körpergefühl habe dank der musik wusste
ich zum beispiel was sich mit den händen
machen musste bereits als vierjähriger
wusste ich wie man den bogen in der hand
hält dieses wissen als musiker hat mir
geholfen die bewegungen umzusetzen
das ist unglaublich schwierig nach einem
schlaganfall hat man ja nicht vergessen
was man tun soll
man kann es einfach nicht mehr beim
wieder gehen lernen habe ich als
fußgänger räume neuer lieb ich glas auch
sehr viel über städte
ich habe nähe und distanz durch erfahren
und gemerkt wie bedrückend
menschenmassen sein können besser
people's mann ist eine art erwachsenes
kind das lernt sich im raum zu bewegen
die ganz die ganze raum wahrnehmung hat
sich verändert und sie ist jetzt
sprechen die städte an ein großes thema
war ihr neues buch gerade jetzt dazu
erschienen ist die offene stadt sie
leben selbst in zwei großstädten in
london und den new york wo sie auch
lange unterrichtet haben muss ich
arbeiten
ich stelle mir das leben ziemlich
hektisch vor sowie in tokio und anderen
großstädten wir sehen hier bilder
menschenmassen muss ich doch jeder
allein führt orientierungslos vielleicht
auch haben sie das gefühl die menschen
leiden
sie sind ein wahrer romantiker
ich hatte noch nie ein interviewer der
so romantisch war die leute leiten
keineswegs unter den menschenmassen
überhaupt nicht wenn sie als 75 jähriger
rentner im altersheim leben wo sie jeden
tag 20 schritte gehen ein oder zwei
leute sehen würden sie diese
manifestation des lebens lieben sie
würden die straße alle mal den ganzen
tag im stuhl dahinvegetieren vorziehen
aber man braucht auch ein rückzugsraum
sie selbst leben glaube ich jetzt auch
außerhalb von london
man packt er in dieser ruhe man kann da
kann man einsteigen aber man muss doch
wieder hast meine kinder und enkel sind
gerne auf dem land das ließe sich
vielleicht psychologisch erklären
ich halte das ein paar tage aus aber um
auf die menschenmassen zurückzukommen
sie haben mich ja zum schlaganfall
befragt interessanterweise ist eine der
ersten erfahrungen nach einem
schlaganfall dass man den kontakt mit
menschenmengen schuld
man leidet unter reizüberflutung beim
laufen fühlt man schwindel und man
fürchtet in jemanden hinein zu stürzen
im buch beschreibe ich wie ich in berlin
die kantstraße sporthalle zu umgehen
lernen genutzt habe das ist eine schöne
lange straße mit vielen cafés und
asiatischen essensangeboten was ich sehr
liebe ich erwähne das weil man nach
einem schlaganfall interessanterweise
gerade in der menschenmasse spürt dass
man auf dem weg der genesung ist wenn
man merkt dass der eigene körper sich
wieder sicher in der menge bewegen kann
karies krank aber wie gesagt sie sind
hoffnungslos romantisch menschen
brauchen die menge
sie brauchen die stimulation durch
menschen die anders sind
sie sind nicht für die lehre gemacht und
wir wissen ja von gerät das man
einsamkeit auch in der menge verspüren
kann die frage ob diese einsamkeit oder
diese innere leere auch in einer
großstadt erlebbar sein kann und worüber
sie das angesprochen haben die begegnung
zwischen andersartigen menschen in einer
stadt in öffentlichen räumen mit
andersdenkenden aus anderen kulturen
anderen altersklassen und so das findet
ja gar nicht so stark habe ich den
eindruck sie selbst sagen die
gesellschaft ist irgendwie so müssen
realistisch geworden so wie es eine
stammesgesellschaft verschiedenen
stämmen die armen haben nichts mehr zu
tun mit den reichen die reichen leben im
zentrum die anwältin an die händler
gedrängt
ist nicht die gefahr von segregation von
abt splittung unserer gesellschaft der
ganzen ungleichheit der sozialen
die zunehmend gibt ja dieses risiko
besteht in vielen städten zerstören wir
die räume in denen unterschiedliche
menschen aufeinander treffen
ich weiß nicht wie das in deutschland
ist aber in den usa geht rassismus
einher mit der tatsache dass man wenig
zeit mit personen andere ethnien
verbringt weil man räumlich getrennt von
ihnen lebt in meiner praktischen
arbeiter stadtplaner interessiere ich
mich für plätze wo menschen
bedrohungsfall aufeinandertreffen können
wo man nicht miteinander reden muss aber
sich im selben raum aufhält
für deutschland mag das vielleicht
trivial klingen aber in starke regierten
ländern wie den vereinigten königreich
oder vor allem den usa verbringen
rassisten sehr wenig zeit mit menschen
mit einem anderen hintergrund
in meinem buch beschreibe ich strategien
wie dies beiläufig und informell
geschehen kann indem man zum beispiel
schulen oder krankenhäuser so plant das
sie am rand zwischen zwei wohngegenden
liegen und nicht in deren zentrum
und wie vorher angekündigt geflüchtete
bei der arbeit auf menschen treffen die
nicht flüchtlinge sind sie haben recht
tatsächlich beobachten wir dass städte
ihren eigentlichen charakter verlieren
und welches nahezu geschlossenen städten
werden sich sie regieren
ich bin vielleicht etwas zu ausführlich
aber seit aristoteles wissen wir dass
die wirtschaft floriert wenn
unterschiedliche menschen zusammenkommen
und dadurch synergien konflikte und
zusammenhalt entstehen robusteste teil
der lokalen wirtschaft gemeinden in
landen sind die grenzzäune zwischen den
einzelnen gemeinschaften im herzen der
islamischen gemeinschaft im osten lampen
es läuft wenig das geld wird an den
rändern verdient da wo man untereinander
handel treibt und kunden von außen kommt
im buch überlege ich mir praktische
strategien wie man diese durchlässigkeit
schafft damit leute in der masse auf
menschen treffen die anders sind die sie
nicht kennen und vielleicht auch nicht
mögen
das ist eine gute regel für plätze zu
schulen und für das alter
[Musik]
etwas fand ich noch bemerkenswert im
kriegsversehrten amsterdam hat ein
architekt aldo van eyck im straßen wie
wäre kleine parks geschaffen in der
spielen konnten alte sich trafen und
marktstände aufgestellt wurden
die spielplätze waren nicht mit zäunen
von der straße abgetrennt
sie fragt ob dies nicht gefährlich wäre
für die kinder meinte er
diese müssten lernen in einer komplexen
umgebung zu leben
viele der alten gingen in den park und
zu trinken da waren also die kinder am
spielen der verkehr rauscht vorbei
die alten tranken ihren sinn jede ging
seinen dingen nach das ist eine umgebung
die die menschen kompetenter macht mit
komplexität und zu gehen
plätze an den rändern zwischen zwei
ethnischen gemeinschaften schaffen
kompetentere menschen
ich finde das sehr einleuchtend diese
durchlässigkeit dass es die braucht
diese öffentlichen räume dass die
durchmischung funktioniert ganz
beiläufig kann man sagen ich hatte vor
kurzem gelegenheit mit dem schweizer
architekten jacques herzog zu sprechen
von herzog ein alter freund gebaut hat
und er sieht das ganz ähnlich wir hören
uns eine kurze steile hast ihn
gespeichert
diese informelle aufenthaltsqualität die
die tate modern aus der turbinenhalle
ist vielleicht anders unsere
gelungensten beispiele für diese für
diese absicht und auch dass bereits west
gleichermaßen
da geht leute hin und hängen einfach
herum die treffen sich nicht weiß jetzt
ins olympiastadion gehen wollen oder
weil sie ins museum gehen wollen sind
sie es ist eine plattform
auch banner ort wo du einfach gerne best
und das ist seine art mehr wert ist zu
sagen würde das wort aber es ist etwas
das natürlich der bau haben möchte dass
die menschen gerne hingehen aber es ist
schwierig zu formulieren mache mal einen
raum an dem die menschen dann gerne
sehen
ja sie haben sie gesagt sie seien
befreundet mit sagt herzog dann sehen
sie dass wahrscheinlich sehr hinterher
ja ich teile seine ansicht
[Musik]
die idee dahinter ist dass form und
funktion sich nicht eins zu eins
entsprechen wenn sich bei einer oper
auch eine arztpraxis ein café oder ein
nagelstudio befindet und dort auch
teenager abhängen können ohne etwas
bestimmtes zu tun hat man einen
lebendigen platz geschaffen ohne all das
ist es ein lebloser ort genial an der
erweiterung der tate modern ist dass
vieles gleichzeitig geschieht
sie ist im jargon der stadtplaner ein
synchroner platz solche räume sind
selten geworden stadtzentrum sind
tagsüber voller menschen
aber nach 18 uhr und land weil wir keine
synchronizität geschaffen haben
das gleichzeitig verschiedene dinge
passieren auf diesen plätzen die
unterschiedlich bespielt werden
wichtig ist die gleichzeitigkeit sie
sollten nicht sequenziell sondern
synchron sein und hier spielt auch der
kapitalismus wieder eine rolle bei
vielen international finanzierten
bauprojekten in stetten entsprechen sich
formen funktion stark
ich hatte ein langes gespräch mit einer
person die in ein bürogebäude in
hongkong investierte ich fragte sie
warum sie keine schule in das gebäude
integriert
sie verwarf die idee weil in diesem high
class gebäude keine kinder herumtollen
sollten
ich fragte was daran falsch wäre und sie
meinte niemand würde ein gebäude mit
mischnutzung finanzieren
in schwellenländern in chinesischen oder
lateinamerikanischen städten wollen
internationale investoren genau wissen
wofür sie bezahlen
für die städte ist das tödlich ich fand
es ganz interessant aus ihrer biografie
gelesen habe sie sind 1943 geboren in
einem armenviertel in chicago in einer
sozialen wohnsiedlung ihre eltern waren
russische einwanderer ihre mutter also
beides gruppen kommunisten ihre mutter
heide
ihre mutter war sozialarbeiterin und
allein erziehen weil der vater ging dann
zurück nach nach spanien nach europa und
ich hab' gefunden die ihr ganzes werk
die leitmotive das spiegelt sich ihre
kindheit ihre biografie darin
ich fürchte ja
auch seine gründe ich wuchs in einem
armenviertel auf uns war nicht bewusst
wie rau die gegend war
wir kannten ja nichts anderes es war
einfach normal es gab viel gewalt ich
blicke ohne rührseligkeit auf diese zeit
zurück wenn ich feststelle dass wir in
dieser unterprivilegierten nachbarschaft
auch bestimmte fähigkeiten entwickelten
wie man mit banken gewalt umgeht zum
beispiel ich bin froh dass ich nicht
mehr dort lebe und zu einem satten durch
wahr geworden bin
aber es war der ausgangspunkt eines
reflexionsprozess mich in dieser
schwierigen gegen zurechtzufinden hat
mir auch gutes gebracht mir und anderen
die es überlebt haben
das war aber nicht für alle kinder so
das ist keine medizin für alle
daraus hat sich die haltung ergeben die
meinen büchern zu grunde liegt mit
schwierigkeiten umzugehen anstatt de so
zu gestalten dass sie einfach sicher und
intuitiv klar sind ist stimulierend und
entwicklungsfördernde fehlt dass unsere
heutige zeit
absolut denken sie an unserem
nutzerfreundlichen computer bei denen
nur das lernt was zur bedienung
erforderlich ist aber nichts über das
funktionieren eines computers ein nutzer
unfreundliches system willi nix weiß
nicht ob sie das canon ist schwierig
aber macht auch spaß weil man im
ständigen kampf stets etwas lernt
ich würde das nicht überall empfehlen
ein arzt sollte nicht auf diese art
operieren die kommerzielle seite des
kapitalismus besagt dass schwieriges
oder anspruchsvolles oder gefährliches
unbedingt vermieden werden muss
das ist ja auch teil der rhetorik bei
ausländerfeindlichen haltungen dass es
schwierig ist mit diesen leuten
umzugehen weil man nicht weiß wer sie
sind sie eine andere sprache sprechen
andere erfahrungen gemacht haben wie
schrecklich sie sind keine kopie von uns
das ist dumm
man schadet sich letztlich selbst wenn
man es sich so einfach macht wie das
people damage finde ich interessant dass
genau diese widerstände fehlen und auch
die bereitschaft widerstände zu
überwinden
für sie spielt das üben auch eine
wichtige rolle
und beim üben macht man das ja
eigentlich man versucht das was man
nicht kann über längere zeit dauern zu
verbessern geht uns das üben verloren in
unserer gesellschaft
[Musik]
es gibt nicht so sehr ums leben
in unserem bildungssystem loten wir
problematiken nicht genügend aus
intelligent kürzel a tec attest wirklich
intelligente kinder zum beispiel lösen
einen test nicht so schnell wie sie
könnten weil eine falsche antwort ihre
neugierde weckt und sie sich fragen
warum sie wohl falsch ist
problemlösung hat immer auch mit dem
finden von problemen zu tun was ein
wesentlicher aspekt gute denkarbeit ist
die kinder nur die richtige antwort
verlangen ignorieren problematische
aspekte
ich lehre am mpi einer sehr technischen
uni und mir fällt auf dass diese
wirklich guten techniker dort ständig
die frage stellen was hier falsch ist
oder wie etwas schief gehen könnte sie
haben eine denkhaltung die
schwierigkeiten mit einschließt das
lässt mich an meine eigene kindheit
denken dass der umgang mit dem
schwierigen eine möglichkeit war zu
überleben
das war und 80
die begegnung mit fremden personen mit
anders denken dann ist auch so ein
widerstand erst machen wie furchtbar die
sind ja nicht wie ich fand es
interessant das sieht aber in diesem
zusammenhang zwei jüdischen philosophen
des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts ins spiel
bringen wenn es um diese beziehung geht
die wir zu unseren nachbarn haben zu
menschen denen wir begegnen aber ich
will nicht so gut kennen emanuel wie
nass und marcel martin buber und können
sie ganz kurz erläutern inwiefern diese
beiden personen was wir von denen lernen
können in unserem umgang mit nachbarn
ich erzähle ihnen gerne etwas über le
wieners die nicht gegen ende seines
lebens kennenlernte levin us hatte eine
sehr schwierige zeit während des kriegs
hier sehen wir ihn erstaunlich
er trug immer dieselbe krawatte
in dieser schrecklichen zeit
reflektierte er über die frage wie das
miteinander leben gelingen kann wenn man
sich nicht mit dem anderen identifiziert
wie man jemanden respektieren kann den
man nicht versteht
für ihn war ein nachbar jemand mit dem
man seite an seite lebt ohne zu
versuchen die unterschiede zwischen
ihnen auszulöschen
[Musik]
huber führte er darüber einen langen
streit über ging nach israel und liebte
unter den seinen in seinem buch ich und
du betrachtete ihr die frage der
interdependenz für levin us stellte sich
die frage anders der andere geht über
die eigene begrifflichkeit hinaus levin
us totalisiert die welt nicht wie er das
nennt er schaut sich an was außerhalb
der welt liegt die man fassen kann wie
einen globus das unendliche unbegrenzte
ganz im sinne jüdische weisheit die auch
immer weisheit ist das ist eine andere
art den anderen zu betrachten als die
unterschiede auslöschen zu wollen
das hat auch praktische bedeutung für
mich in meiner drahtenden tätigkeit für
die uhr
dort gilt viele arzt das klischee dass
man in einem konflikt das gegenseitige
verständnis für ein
das schärfen müsse das scheint mir zu
kurz gegriffen
es geht nicht darum sich besser zu
verstehen um zusammenleben zu können
sondern wie man zusammenleben kann ohne
sich wirklich zu verstehen hat deshalb
sind viele unserer konflikt
lösungsversuche auch gescheitert heute
aber lehnt man sich wieder an levin as
an das ideal war das falsche mann soll
sich verstehen dabei geht es darum
miteinander zu leben auch wenn man sich
immer an fremde bleibt
ich möchte zum schluss mit ihnen an
wissen über über visionen noch sprechen
die ich bei ihnen wenig finde ehrlich
gesagt ich finde sie sind dann
unglaublich scharfer kritischer
beobachter unserer gesellschaft aber
wenn ich ja nach einer vision nach einer
utopie suche dann finde ich da keine h
warum ich glaube nicht an utopien
ich habe eine sehr praktische
herangehensweise
wir suchen in der stadtplanung ja nicht
den idealen plan oder die perfekte
lösung sondern unterschiedliche
möglichkeiten mit einem problem
umzugehen
egal ob es dabei um die fenstergröße
geht oder die gestaltung einer straße
oder die räume zwischen nachbarschaft
deshalb heißt das buch ja auch offene
stadt
stadtplanung verlief meist über
masterpläne und war von oben herab
verordnet
als alternative dazu verfolgte man allzu
oft nur eine andere vision die sich dem
masterplan widersetzte das ist die
falsche vorgehensweise wenn man eine
stadt offen gestalten will
man sollte sich über viele mögliche wege
mit ihren vor und nachteilen gedanken
machen
im buch stelle ich fünf möglichkeiten
für räumliche oder soziale fragen zu
problematisieren um beziehungen offener
zu gestalten menschen zu nachbarn zu
machen anstatt sie einander näher zu
bringen
ich bin kein idealist es ist harte
arbeit wir forschen manchmal ist es
schwierig und wir stecken auch manchmal
in einer sackgasse fest
nicht umsonst heißt ihre diese drei
bücher unter dem projekt homo faber
damit der mensch aus auersmacher und
genau diese dieses eine merkbare haben
wir schon angesprochen diese kuriosität
die durchlässigkeit von räumen dass das
gegeben ist sie haben zusammen mit ihrer
frau saskia sassen die selbst soziologin
ist und mit ökonomie und so etwas wie
ein manifest herausgegeben
quito papers für die stadt des
einundzwanzigsten jahrhunderts was
würden sie sagen ist das wichtigste für
die stadt der zukunft
das kann ich ihnen leider nicht sagen
meine kristallkugel ist dafür zu trübe
für uns beide ist aber die praktische
frage zentral wie man den öffentlichen
raum über den konsum raum hinaus
erweitern kann
wie man also öffentliche plätze mit
aktivitäten füllt die orden mit anderen
teilt in den titel papers haben saskia
richard barrett und ich pläne für das
un-treffen ausgearbeitet worin wir uns
nicht über die übel des kapitalismus
auslassen
die sind ausreichend bekannt sondern
über eine alternative bei der
öffentliche räume komplexer werden das
fußt auf der systemtheorie bei der es
darum geht dinge komplexe und nicht
klarer zu machen
deshalb ist meine kristallkugel auch
verdunkelt wir sollten nicht nach der
einen antwort suchen sondern nach
unterschiedlichen praktiken die uns in
richtungen führen die wir noch nie
angedacht haben ebenso beim thema arbeit
hier sollten wir eine debatte darüber
führen was es bedeutet ohne arbeit zu
sein und es uns nicht mit der zahlung
von arbeitslosengeld einfach zu machen
warum ist arbeit so wichtig diese
schwierigen frage muss man sich stellen
in dieser umwelten kristallkugel war mir
die frage wichtig wie man eine stadt
offener machen kann
so klar ist einfach zu sieg regiert wir
haben gedacht wenn wir so einen großen
gast bei uns haben stellen wir auch die
ganz großen fragen und sie gelten als
public intellectuals eine intellektuelle
der zu den großen fragen der zeit auch
hier stellung nimmt was würden sie sagen
sind die sind die drei größten
herausforderungen vor der die menschheit
jetzt steht 3 3
was haben sie aus der luft gegriffen
2 lassen sie mich zwei dinge ansprechen
als arbeits forscher interessiert mich
wie man technologie so einsetzen kann
dass menschen gedeihen und nicht
herabgewürdigt und missbraucht werden
wie bei facebook und google
diese frage stellt sich insbesondere bei
der künstlichen intelligenz am
arbeitsplatz über ein anderes großes
thema das mich beschäftigt oder dass ich
bei meiner arbeit für die uno gestoßen
bin habe ich leider bislang noch nichts
geschrieben nämlich über die frage nach
der auswirkung des klimawandels auf die
stadtgestaltung pokal in einem
jahrhundert werden unsere städte wegen
des klimawandels völlig andere
umweltbedingungen haben als wir sie
jetzt kennen
das sind für mich die beiden großen
themen der zukunft
darf ich fragen die stadt foren städte
verändern ist es war der meeresspiegel
steigt die temperaturen steigen woran
denkt sie da konkret
es sind viele dinge für einzelne städte
ist es der meeresspiegel bei anderen die
steigenden wetter extreme heißt halt für
viele städte die wüstenbildung durch
mangel an grundwasser
das wird viele formen annehmen deren
verlauf meist unvorhersehbar ist
wir wissen zwar dass es zu mehr stürmen
kommen wird wo und wann die aber
auftauchen entzieht sich unserer
kenntnis
für die stadtplanung stellt sich die
frage ob wir uns den klimawandel
anpassen was wir bisher schlecht gemacht
habe ich möchte dass trump wort hier
nicht in den mund nehmen aber diese
katastrophe wird eintreten
und hier stellt sich die frage wie man
mit etwas umgeht was unlösbar ist und
schaden bringen wird auch deshalb
interessiere ich mich im moment nicht
wirklich für die politik das thema ist
bei vielen politikern nicht wirklich auf
die ihren radar weil es da keine stimmen
zu gewinnen gibt und es hoch komplex ist
überlassen sie das thema gerne anderen
genau wie das thema automatisierung erst
weniger vertraut ist als das der
immigranten die unsere grenzen stürmen
deshalb verweigere ich mich der
kristallkugel
sie wollen eine antwort auf strukturelle
probleme für die es keine antworten gibt
den ich zu streng mit ihnen
ich bin im nachteil neben dem
klimawandel die digitalisierung oder
automatisierung als eines der größten
probleme kann das nicht auch eine chance
sein dass endlich nicht mehr vier
menschen die stupide repetitive arbeit
machen müssen sondern maschinen und wir
endlich was sinnvolles machen können
sowie gärtnern oder kochen gerne hierher
das könnten wir aber wie wäre es wohl
zwölf stunden pro tag sieben tage lang
zu gärten wie wird sich das an
wurde ein bäcker zu sein zwölf stunden
lang sieben tage die woche
aber wenn die wenn die maschinen die
arbeit für uns machen könnten jedoch
verschiedene dinge machen
kg kritiken schreiben sowie karl marx
sich das vorstellt
7 und vielleicht liegt ja auch das
grundlegende problem kommunistische
regime bei der annahme dass menschen
nichts leisten sondern letztendlich
[ __ ] wollen
deshalb habe ich dieses homo farbe
geschrieben
die idee vom machen wegzukommen ist zur
fantasie der ältere marx glaubte dies
übrigens auch nicht mehr das stammt aus
früheren texten die vorstellung dass man
kein produktiver mensch sein muss dass
man nicht arbeiten muss dass das leben
durch freizeit und vergnügen erfüllt
sein kann ist sehr kindisch
das wäre höchst unbefriedigend für den
menschen
stellen sie sich vor man könnte das
kinder erziehen mechanisierten und
automatisieren und sich all das ersparen
ihr lieben würde dadurch unglaublich
dürftig
es ist ein problem die man sich stellen
muss mit all diesen technischen
möglichkeiten nur der technologischen
katastrophen umzugehen dass diese sturm
backup mir und glaube ich auch uns
sowieso schauen und zuschauern viel zu
denken vielen herzlichen dank dass ihr
euch ja und nach ihren vielen herzlichen
dank fürs zuschauen und fürs mitdenken
nächste woche begrüßte hier meine
kollegin barbara bleisch und heute abend
zeigen wir ihnen in der stadt schöne
kunst den film kongo tribunal von milo
rau schon über acht millionen tote hat
der kongo krieg gefordert doch die
verbrechen des krieges wurden die
juristisch verfolgt nun untersucht ein
symbolisches tribunal diese gräueltaten
und jetzt gleich folgt das abstimmungs
studio bleiben sie also dran und einen
schönen sonntag
[Musik]